the movie is set in a dystopian world
where the sun never rises and it's
always dark a strange occurrence happens
at exactly 12 o'clock every night as
everyone in this world dies for five
minutes and then wakes up with no memory
of what happened at the start of the
movie the protagonist john murdock
awakens in a dark bathroom terrified
with his ass out he has no recollection
of how he got there what he was doing in
the past weeks or even his name after
getting dressed he snoops around the
place until he comes across a briefcase
with the initials kh on it upon opening
it he finds a greeting card from a place
known as shell beach murdoch can't
exactly recall the place but he starts
getting fragments of memories about it
just then the telephone inside the
bathroom starts ringing and he picks it
up hesitantly on the other side a man
who calls himself dr schrieber tells
murdoch that his memory was erased
because of a failed experiment and now
some men are looking for him this adds
to the confusion that murdock is already
experiencing and before the doctor can
say anything else he hangs up following
this murdoch proceeds to check out of
the place which turns out to be a hotel
as he is leaving he comes across a
lady's disfigured corpse seeing this
murdoch becomes terrified and rushes out
of his room and sees three abnormally
tall pale-faced individuals approaching
him when he reaches the lobby he notices
that everyone is asleep even a woman
inside the elevator it's almost as if
they have become lifeless just then the
clock strikes 12 and all the people come
back to life again murdoch finds this
very strange and he leaves the hotel
immediately shortly after the mysterious
men approach the hotel receptionist and
ask him about murdock when he fails to
give an answer they inject him with a
strange substance and kill him elsewhere
a stage performer named emma is
contacted by dr schrieber who tells her
to meet urgently here we get to know
that emma is none other than murdoch's
wife when the two meet dr schrieber
mentions that murdoch's memory has been
totally wiped out and some bad people
are on the hunt for him hence he asks
her to contact him immediately if she
meets murdock although confused emma
agrees in the next scene local police
along with inspector bumstead arrive at
the crime scene in the hotel and start
investigating turns out that it has been
the sixth murder case in the last month
and all of them have the same spiral
symbol drawn on them since murdoch has
been staying there inspector bumstead
immediately suspects him of the crime he
then calls emma to the police station
and warns her to turn her husband in as
he is a wanted criminal meanwhile
murdoch is wandering around the city
confused and scared as he reaches a
place he becomes uneasy and notices that
his fingerprints are glowing after a
while he finds himself in front of a
shell beach advertisement board the same
one from the greeting card he found in
the hotel suitcase curious he climbs up
the advertisement board but suddenly he
is confronted by the three tall men from
earlier who call themselves the
strangers one of them tries to use his
powers on murdoch to make him sleep but
it fails this shocks the strangers but
before they can comprehend anything
murdock uses his telekinetic powers and
subdues the three later we are taken to
the hideout of the strangers which turns
out to be a large underground compound
everyone is in shock that murdoch
possesses telekinetic powers like they
do here we get to know that murdoch was
part of an experiment called imprinting
but he somehow escaped by using his
powers now he has become a wanted man
for the strangers on the other hand emma
returns home from the police station and
finds murdoch waiting for her although
he doesn't seem to remember her he knows
that he lives there as the address was
mentioned in his business card emma
tries to ask murdock about where he was
for the last three weeks but the latter
has no answer to this instead he says
that he didn't even know his name until
he checked his wallet as the two talk
emma reveals that he has been suspected
for the murder of six women this shocks
murdoch and he leaves the place
immediately just before midnight the
strange men gather in their hideout for
a meeting dr schrieber is the only human
among the attendees and it appears that
he is the head of their science
department when the clock strikes
exactly 12 pm the leader of the
strangers mr book emerges from the crowd
and instructs everyone to shut it down
as soon as he says this the strangers go
into a meditation state and the entire
city above stops people go to sleep
regardless of where they are the trains
come to a halt and even all of traffic
stops which is weird you'd think someone
would fall asleep with their foot on the
gas i don't know only murdoch is
unaffected by the strange process
and he wanders around the city in
disbelief he tries to wake some people
up but to no avail meanwhile large
buildings and other infrastructures
begin rising through the underground
indicating that a massive change is
taking place in the city then the
strangers along with dr schrieber head
into the city and begin a process called
tuning in this process they approach
several individuals in the city and
inject them with a syringe so that their
memory is wiped clean after five minutes
when all the strangers have retreated to
the underground the city again comes
back to life and everyone wakes up
however this time they have no
recollection of their past life and have
a completely new identity for instance
someone who is a doctor five minutes ago
may have now become a serial killer
after the tuning the strangers again
shift their focus towards murdock since
it is proving difficult to catch him dr
schrieber has prepared a syringe which
has all the subconscious memories of
murdoch stored in it now all he has to
do is inject it in someone and they will
be able to track murdoch instantly as
everyone stares at him in confusion one
of the senior strangers mr hand emerges
from the crowd and agrees to volunteer
the leader mr book gives the heads up
and soon mr hand is injected with the
strange liquid after convulsing for a
while he finally wakes up with all the
memories of murdoch in the next scene
murdock reaches the subway in search of
shell beach he asks some people about
directions to the place but surprisingly
all of them have forgotten about it
confused he once again stares at the
greeting card and finds the name karl
harris written on it the initials of the
same name were inscribed on the suitcase
back at the hotel later murdoch tracks
down carl's address and visits his home
the old man reminisces about the past
where murdoch was a kid but as expected
he doesn't remember any of it just then
he gets curious and asks carl why it's
always night but the latter simply tells
him to take some rest after murdoch goes
to another room carl secretly calls emma
and informs her about murdoch's arrival
she in turn tells inspector bumstead and
proceeds to the location with him but
sadly mr hand who has been tracking emma
using murdock's memories overhears her
entire conversation when murdoch finds
out that carl has revealed his location
he tries to escape the place but it's
too late the strangers led by mr hand
have already arrived outside and they
start attacking murdoch however using
his extremely complex telekinetic powers
and the will to survive murdoch
continues evading them he somehow
manages to get onto the street but is
again surrounded by the strangers just
as he is about to be apprehended emma
and the inspector arrive in their car
and take him away the scene then cuts to
the police station where inspector
bumstead is interrogating murdoch as he
believes that he is behind the murders
however an agitated murdoch flips the
questions and instead asks the inspector
if he remembers the way to shell beach
as expected bumstead does know the place
but even he cannot seem to recall the
directions then murdock asks him why
they're always experiencing night and
why they have no memories of the day if
they have no memories of it how do they
know it's a thing he even makes a book
levitate to prove his point that they
are dealing with something supernatural
after a while some strangers led by mr
hand enter the police station and start
looking for murdoch they put all the
officers to sleep and head to the cell
however upon reaching it they find that
their target has already escaped in the
meantime murdoch confronts dr schreiber
at a bath house and demands answers he
wants to know what is going on in the
city and why the strangers are after him
the doctor calms them down and reveals
that they are all part of a grand
experiment that the strangers are
conducting just then inspector bumstead
arrives at the scene and takes control
of the doctor here it is revealed that
the inspector himself released murdoch
out of custody as he too wants to find
answers after that the inspector and
murdoch forced the doctor to lead them
to shell beach they get in a car and
start their journey but for some reason
the doctor keeps mentioning that going
there is of no use shortly after they
reach a dead end as a bridge has
mysteriously disappeared hence the three
decide to continue by boat during the
journey dr schrieber finally explains
everything that is happening with the
city he reveals that the strangers are
aliens from another planet and they came
to earth after they almost faced
extinction when they saw the human
population prospering they immediately
decided to emulate them however the
problem was that they didn't have any
souls and that is what differentiates
them from the humans adamant on saving
their race the strangers then created an
entire city abducted humans from
different parts of the world and placed
them there every night at 12 they stop
everyone and install new memories in
them so that they can compare the
different characteristics in humans the
plan is to know everything about the
human soul and become just like them dr
schrieber further mentions that he is
the best psychologist in town and this
is why the strangers don't erase his
memory every night murdoch then asks why
it's always night to which the doctor
replies that the strangers are afraid of
light so they created a city where it's
always dark after a while they arrive at
shell beach only to find that it's
merely a poster on a wall enraged
murdoch and inspector bumstead grab some
iron bars and begin striking the wall
the doctor begs the duo to stop but they
don't listen eventually they break the
wall and are taken aback to find endless
space on the other side this confirms
that the city is a mere experiment and
there will be no escaping it just then
mr hand and his henchmen arrive at the
scene with a captive emma and threaten
murdoch to surrender the inspector
immediately retaliates but he is thrown
out into the abyss before he dies he
witnesses the city floating in space
which is surrounded by nothing but
darkness here we get to know that this
city is just a huge spaceship on the
other hand mr hand uses emma as leverage
and eventually captures murdock in the
next scene murdoch is seen tied to a
chair as the entire stranger community
that's right the whole bald brigade
shouts for his death however their
leader mr book claims that he has other
ideas he summons dr schrieber and asks
him to inject murdock with an imprint
which will transfer his soul into all
the strangers hesitantly the doctor
obliges but instead of the imprint he
injects murdock with another syringe one
which contains all of his memories as
soon as it is administered all of
murdoch's memories flash right in front
of his eyes and it is shown that he was
indeed born in a place called shell
beach because of the memories he now
understands the true nature of his power
and becomes much stronger in one of the
memories dr schreiber appears and tells
murdoch to defeat the strangers and to
take control over the city with this he
gets renewed hope and breaks free from
his bondage he then starts using his
telekinetic powers to throw the
strangers around until mr book
approaches him soon the two start going
hammer and tongs at each other but they
seem to be equally matched their fight
destroys the entire compound so they
continue in the air this time murdoch
reigns supreme when he deflects mr
book's knife and throws it right back at
him finally killing him after the
victory murdoch approaches the doctor
and asks about emma but the latter
mentions that she has already lost her
memory during the last tuning hearing
this murdoch is devastated but he has an
idea to change everything in the last
scene murdoch uses his supreme
telekinetic powers to reform the whole
city he adds an ocean all around repairs
the bridges creates a shell beach and
most importantly brings the sun back by
rotating the spaceship the movie ends as
murdock heads to a pier near the ocean
where a newly transformed emma is
basking in the sun
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching